this is a biological talk with focus on
machine learning so I know that probably
the large majority of you are non
biologists and don't have the background
in biology so I don't expect any prior
knowledge and if I come across any
technical maybe I don't know if I say
some word that you don't understand so
for this please do raise your hand and
just ask and I'll just you know see how
a cooperative are you who from you if
you can raise your hand have heard the
word microbiome okay so that's a large
half who haven't let's see okay good job
so if a I almost everyone I think raise
their arms at some point so the talk of
today is why can't we maintain our
weight after dieting so this work is a
joint project can everyone see the slide
okay with two talented students from
another lab invites money from the lab
over tunnel another Islamic and
Christophe and the question is what
happens when we die so people are very
successful in general in dieting so it's
not that I mean it's not easy to lose
weight but people are successful in
losing weight and there are various
different types of diets you know low
fat diet high carb different types you
know Perl Aaron and people managed to
lose weight and you can see in this
illustration that someone here started
as the obese and then he is doing a diet
he losing his weight and then after some
time now that you look at him he looks
again fat and this is a really known
phenomena it's called the yo-yo effect
where not only do people have a tendency
for a weight loss and weight gain cycles
but if you look over time you can see
that they have an effect where they keep
on and every
increasing their weight over time and
then one has to ask himself whether it's
even good to do a diet because if you
can't maintain a diet you might as well
stay in your original weight and maybe
not gain as much weight and we wanted to
understand what happens and what causes
this yo-yo yo-yo effect and for this we
started by building a mouse model we
wanted to see if we can imitate this
phenomena and if you look here in this
diagram you have here a blue mouse this
blue mouse is eating a high-fat diet
and his weight constantly decreases and
we have a control mice this control mice
is eating just a high carb diet and you
can see that he also gains a weight over
time but this is because he's aging and
they just accumulate weight but it has a
very stable increase in his weight and
now we have a diet a mouse that is going
through these occurrence peri episodes
of gain weight and gain loss so we
initially we put him on a high-fat diet
then we put him on the high carb diet so
he loses weight and he goes back to the
control mice weight then we put him on a
second cycle of high-fat diet and again
he loses his weight and this mouse has
something that is very interesting now
we compare this mice we call this mice a
cycling high-fat diet because he goes
through cycles and we compare this Mouse
to a mouse that we call a high prime
high-fat diet with which we had only
seen once high fat and you can see that
at this time point both mice the high
fat the cycling mice and the prime
high-fat diets they weigh the same but
now when we put both groups on a
high-fat diet you can see that the one
that doesn't have an obese history gains
less weight than the one that already
has an obese history so this area is
marked here in blue and this is exactly
the effect that I'm talking about so we
can already see that we can observe this
phenomenon in mice and this recurrent
obesity induces other unfavorable
metabolic
affects not only weight gain so if we
compare the fast composition in their
body you can see that the cycling
high-fat diet has a higher fat across
his body when he is gaining weight and
he has a higher cholesterol and compared
to the green white and you can the
colors will remain the same throughout
the talk so always you need to compare
the green and the red curve cloth and we
ask is there a memory of previous
obesity and their answer is you can
already say that there is because if you
look at this time point at this time
point do you weigh the same so there is
something different between them so
somehow at this time point although they
look the same if you look at them
something must be something different
there should be some memory that will
cause that at the second time that they
will encounter a high-fat diet the mouse
who has already had a high-fat diet
before would gain more weight so we try
to understand what is this memory and we
looked at very different parameters we
try to understand what could be this
memory effect we looked at different
metabolic features so for example this
is know maybe lots of details but the
point is to say that we tested lots of
phenotypes there if you do like checking
how how how diabetic they are at that
time point so let's go back for a second
everything that I'm going to show you
now our measurement at that time point
because this is a time point which is
critical to understand what is the
difference between the group and at that
time point we check different parameters
works for example there they have the
same glucose response when they put you
put them on sugar and and different to
say similar insulin levels and we check
for different physiologic features so
they burn the same amount of energy at
time point zero when they weigh the same
so it's not about energy expenditure and
it's not about food consumption they eat
the same so it's it's not that they the
one mice eats more than the other one it
counters high-fat diet and also we look
at different in new features of their
immune system and again they look the
same so what is this memory
and the answer is I can already tell you
that the microbiome is the difference
and since I don't expect anyone to know
what is the microbiome so let's let's
give a few minutes about saying what is
the microbiome so the microbiome is
generally the entire microbes that
reside on the host and the large
majority of microbes resides in our gut
so if you're in humans for example we
have about two kilos of bacteria inside
our Agathe which is a lot it's like
about our brain you consider you can
consider it as another organ and it has
a lot of functionalities so a lot of
these dates and different you can
already know it's in the very simple
case you know you eat something rotten
then you feel bad it's probably because
of bacteria but not only that you can
find more and more articles that are
linking associating between different
disease even cancer to bacteria and in
this case we were also very excited to
understand whether there is a microbiome
pattern that can can show this memory
effect and the type of data that we're
looking at when we're saying microbiome
is a data that is very interesting for a
data scientist it's usually a very large
data set if you can think about it in
this case we have here different mice
and so these could be the rows and the
columns here would be the bacteria and
usually when you want to examine you
want to examine like a large data set of
n on n on M matrix then one thing many K
in many cases you would want to see is
maybe to visualize the data so a very
known way to do it is to use a principal
component analysis and just a word about
whoever is not familiar with it it's
basically let's say you only have it's
usually used for dimensionality
reduction so for visualization but what
it does it changes the axis of your data
so let's say bacteria 1 in bacteria 2
could be your x and y axes and let's say
you only have two features here bacteria
1 and book 3
actually that this is all you had so all
the points here could we will rely on
this plane and then if you ask what is
the axis that has the most information
the most variance on it you would tell
the W has the largest variance so this
would be the first principal component
the second principal component is you're
looking for an axis which is orthogonal
for the FIR to the first one and still
maintains the second largest variance in
the data so in this case this is the
vector V and now with with the with the
axis is W and V you don't lose any
information if you plot all points now
using these two accesses but you can
even choose to even disregard access V
because W and still holds the majority
of the information and this is exactly
what you do if you have n bacteria and
you so you can choose to look at two
dimensions one dimension three
dimensions you can do more than that and
we asked how does the microbiome
composition look so our looking at time
point zero time point zero is before
even the experiment began it's just all
mice are the same then looking at the
first principal component the second
principal component this is what you
have here at the bottom accesses then
all mice look the same here each dot
again represents a mouse it represents
the birth serial composition of the
first two principal components and now
the plot above shows you like the
timeline of what is happening here if
you look at a time point where we give
the cycling mice the high-fat diet you
can see that the group of the cycling my
separate the microbiome from the group
of those who haven't ever seen high fat
diet and now after obesity which is this
time point you can see a separation
where the high-fat diets are still very
different and the cycling mice went a
little bit back but still they didn't
return fully to their original
microbiome state and this is what we can
consider as a memory because
hold some information and we wanted to
establish that this indeed this
microbiome is causative of the extra
weight game and what we do as we give
them antibiotics so now what we do is we
take we take the mice who are fat we put
them on a diet and at this time we give
all groups antibiotics including those
who are dieting and now when we put them
again on a high-fat diet and we compare
them to the group who only encounter for
the first time a high-fat diet you can
see that they gain the same amount of
weight and now here only showing the
first PC you can see exactly this but
after a BCP plus antibiotics the control
group and the cycling group are
indistinguishable so this is very nice
because it proves the point that you
give some microbiome you give
antibiotics and it causes a real change
but giving a antibiotics is like taking
a hammer five kilos and like dropping on
the mice it causes a really big change
in their microbiome and we wanted to see
something which is maybe a bit more
delicate we wanted to see if the
microbiome alone has the capability of
transferring this phenomena of extra
exacerbated weight regain so what we do
we have an invite line invite man we
have a germ-free facility where we have
sterile mice and this offers us the
opportunity to actually see something
causative to actually only give the mic
only give them the microbiome and see
what happens
and this is what we do we we take this
time point the time point where the
cycling mice are the same as those of
the control group and at that time point
we take their stool sample stool is
khaki so yes yes I I deal with stool so
at that time point we take the stool
sample from either the cycling the mouse
who have has an
history or we take the stool sample of
the control mice who has never been fat
in this stool would give it to two
groups we we give this stool - germ-free
mice and now the germ-free mice you can
now see what happens when we put that
mouse on a high-fat diet we can check if
it will gain more than expected weight
gain or not and this is what we do and
this is exactly what you see now this
orange curve is the weight gain that the
germ-free mice accumulate when they have
the donor from a cycling which which is
the exo beasts mice and if you compare
it to getting a high-fat diet eating a
high-fat diet but getting the microbiome
from the control group you have less
gained weight and this goes the same for
the glucose response meaning that they
are more diabetic after this germ-free
tray after this microbiome transfer so
the next thing that we thought would be
really interesting is to predict what
what would be the weight we gain now
that at that time point we let's say we
will look at the two mice and maybe only
by their microbiome composition we can
predict how much gain daily weight again
and if you think about it at the
clinical perspective that would be that
maybe if it will work or also on people
then maybe you can go to the doctor you
can give him a stool sample and tell in
your condition and then maybe he can you
know tailor of personalized medicine for
you based on your microbiome and this is
what we do we at that time point like I
said we only take the microbiome a at
the data set this is the matrix of the
data and we build a machine learning
predictive model and we ask two
questions we have two prediction tasks
one we want to see if using the
microbial composition if we can predict
the history meaning if we can predict if
this stool belongs to an X obese mice
or does it belong to the control group
and the second which is a much more
complicated question is to predict what
would be the percent of their weight
gain so the first one is the
specification problem and the second one
is a regression problem that you want to
answer okay so to do the classification
problem we use random forest classifier
which is an ensemble classifier meaning
that we it's built on many classifiers
these are all parameters that you can
play with where each one is a tree it's
a simple tree and eventually you take
this forest of all of the trees together
and you do a majority vote now that you
get a new sample you will check what
does each tree alone predict if it's
going to be the control or the exobase
mice and according to the majority vote
you decide what is the answer and for
the gradient and for the regression
problem of waste prediction we do a
gradient boosting regression what is
gradient boosting so ready and boosting
again you have here your data set this
is the features it's X you have your
predictive weight gain which is why for
every Mouse this is the eye and what you
want to do the objective would be to
minimize the distance between the
original Y and your predicted Y and it's
built again on simple trees and each
tree is a wig tree and at every stage of
the gradient boosting you build another
tree but the first at first you want to
predict Y but in the second stage you
build another tree but this time you try
to predict the residual times this some
X some learning curve and if this
learning curve if this learning
parameter is small then it reduces the
chance of overfitting because you're
actually learning the residual at each
time so you want to improve with time
and this is what we do
and you what we what we observed is that
the first task which was the prediction
task we do a really really really good
job it's predicting almost perfect job
and you could maybe also imagine that
that would be the result after you've
seen the PCA because you've seen that
it's that it's easy with your eyes it
was a clear separation between the
groups and you can ask okay so maybe the
regression of the predicting how much
would be the weight gain maybe it's also
a simple task and the answer is no it's
not as easy because you can see that
this is one group of mice and this is
another group of mice so they can gain
you can see that they're different right
you get a correlation but it's not very
good if you just predict only based you
know if you only X the feature was only
if it was an X obese mice our control
you don't really get a really good score
and the question is how good can we get
and based only on the microbiome as
features we get a really nice actually
correlation of 0.56 but and the thing is
we can do a lot better we can get to
0.72 and how do we do that and this is
actually an open question because these
are the features that I'm using and
maybe a lot of feature engineering can
do a lot better but what we did here we
discovered that if you tell the
predictor that you have a really good
feature then you really help it so the
feature that we told it that it's really
good to use is a the predicted obese
history so we already know that we're
really good at predicting if you're a
myself the control group or the X obese
group and now we would like to feed this
information in so there are two ways to
do that you can either just add another
feature which is the predicted mouse
phenotype and use that is another input
feature and this is actually not bad but
you can do actually a lot better and
what we found that does the best is
do a two-step it's already both both are
two-step right if you if I use the
output of the classification problem and
now uses another input so this is like
it's like a stacking problem so we use
we have two steps but what we've done as
we've done something a bit different
which is taking our predictor and once
we predicted what is the mouse history x
obese or saline
now with the gradient boosting we only
train it on the group that is relevant
that we think will give would be good
so we predict only based on X will be
slice or based or we train another
predictor based only on the slim mice
and we do a live one cross-validation in
both and this resulted in the result
with their outputs here is all that you
see another nice thing that you can do
basically and to ask which features are
important and we rank them and we indeed
found that in the top pin there are many
interesting bacteria actually
lactobacillus is one that is very
familiar it's something that you have in
your yogurt you can do that if it's with
two trees you can look at where it's in
the hierarchy this feature or if it with
a regression then you can look at the
coefficients and next going back to
biology we are if we can treat this
relapsing obesity because now we know
that the microbiome is causal so you
know you can give people maybe
antibiotics but again antibiotics is a
really harsh solution we would like to
actually see how if we can do something
a lot more subtle maybe probiotics or
prebiotics something that would be like
better as a solution and what we've done
here as we wanted to check whether
giving bacteria by itself which you
could imitate maybe as probiotics you
know give someone a pillow which
contains bacteria if that can ameliorate
improve the outcome so here what we do
is we take the mice which are having a
bee
history and at the time point where
there slim we give them a microbiome
transplant either from a control mice
that have never gone through obese
episodes or from you know the same type
of donor like an obese mice it's like
the control group and what we see is
that if you had before the cycling red
curve now that you give the transplant
from a control group you get this orange
curve meaning that with probiotics you
have the potential to eliminate this
extra weight gain so this is very nice
and what we've done next we wanted to
ask maybe now that we understand that
bacteria are causing it maybe we can
actually do something more subtle even
than giving bacteria to to the mice we
try to see which compounds change
between the control group and the
exobase group water compounds we
actually looked at which metabolites
what what happens when they eat what
changes so what is the difference in the
composition of the of the compounds in
their gut between the two groups and we
find that there are two types of
molecules both belonging to their
flavonoid family it's a family it's a
molecules that are plant-based and they
have a plant origin they cause opinion
in and are in Jenin but the names are
not really important and we we've
noticed that before obesity these
compounds are high but after obesity
they remain a during obesity and after
they remain low for a very very long
time so 15 which is a very long time in
the mouth diet and actually we've
noticed that only after half a year like
about 20-something weeks it goes back to
normal the levels and these molecules
have like an antibiotic effect and in
the bacteria actually they don't like it
so what what we've encountered that is
that those who are the ex obese mice
have more bacteria who
to break this molecule so what we've
done is we've given at that time pointed
here where they're slim we've given them
for a long time this a the fill of Anna
leads from either group as a supplement
in what we can see is that when we give
this supplement then again we get a nice
a lower increase in the weight games
like you have here so with it this is
also a very good solution and this is
actually eating like something which is
a plant-based so I will summarize the
talk what we found is that we have a
mouse model for the yo-yo effect we
found that the gut microbiome feature is
a memory like function we found that the
microbiome is necessary and both
sufficient to induce this enhanced
metabolic derangement upon weight regain
using machine learning approaches we can
accurately predict the mouse history and
also more difficulty the weight gain and
my take-home message from this
prediction task is that sometimes using
a pipeline would give you a better
result because it's forcing
specialization and we found that
metabolic induces alterations which are
good in this case ameliorate the
phenomena of weight gain and this could
serve as potential number therapeutics
in help of solving the ineffective
long-term weight management solutions
and with that I would like to thank my
advisor around Sega and the lab a from
London of them the mates from there
thank you
if you have any questions try adding the
measurements of flavonoids into the
regression model later no we didn't do
that for to predict is I would get now
less no we didn't do that yes you did
you were assembling the microbiome
content use this tool oh you like open
good mouth no we don't need to open the
mouth it's actually a very good question
because when you look at stool you only
look at the distal gut and you can ask
maybe maybe there along the path you
have a different composition of guts and
we actually we didn't need to kill mice
in that case so these are stool samples
we just take the DNA out of it there's
an essential error because of it not
genuine and content it's a genuine
content but if yes yes yes yes ah the
thing is we've tried we didn't go really
deep into feature engineering and
different types of models because
basically I think we got a really really
good result we were really surprised
actually to get something in biology
which is so correlative is pretty much
amazing I can assume that maybe with
feature engineering perhaps we can do a
bit better but I don't know if you can
do a lot better okay thank you
[Applause]